[Musik]
wie geht's uns heute wir haben
tatsächlich unfassbar viel auf unserer
Skyblock mit Luca To-Do-Liste hier meine
Damen und Herren von daher dürfen wir
gar nicht lange Zeit verlieren Sache
Nummer Bruno die mir in die Kommentare
geschrieben wurde dieser Baum da hinten
ist ein Mangroven Baum
und man gerufen keine Ahnung wie es
genau ausgesprochen wird der hat Holz
ich habe mich in der letzten Folge
gefragt warum da irgendwie kein Holz kam
der ist wohl irgendwie versteckt in der
Baumkrone oben drin deswegen meine Frage
an euch brauche ich diesen Mann großen
Baum für die Challenges oder kann ich
dir noch einfach man rufenbaum sein
lassen weil ich will jetzt nicht erst
richtig bei Nacht da hinten noch mal
rüber laufen oder irgendwas abbauen wenn
ich erst recht erst gar nicht benötige
oder brauche für die Challenges also
schreibt mir das mal gerne bitte unten
in die Kommentare was mir auch noch
geschrieben wurde und erstmal ganz kurz
euer ganzes Feedback abzuarbeiten was
wirklich wieder enorm unter der letzten
Folge mir wurde nämlich auch noch
geschrieben Luca diese Phantome die hier
spawnen werden zwangsläufig in den
nächsten ein zwei Nächten weil ich ja
nicht schlafe weil ich ja keine Wolle
habe um mir im Bett zu kaufen diese
Phantome kann ich abwehren durch ein
Dach das haben wir in der letzten Folge
schon erfahren habe ich ein bisschen
hinterfragt warum die kommen doch wenn
ich nicht schlafe da bringt ein Dach ja
nichts na ja die können mich nicht
angreifen wenn ich ein Dach habe die
Sache ist allerdings dass ich das auch
nicht so ganz sehe weil ich will jetzt
nicht unbedingt hier unterm die ganze
Zeit chillen von daher lasse ich das
einfach so erstmal und wenn es dann
soweit ist dann werde ich halt mein
wahres Wunder erleben wahrscheinlich
aber ich finde das einfach nicht schön
wenn jetzt hier ein Dach drüber ist von
daher na ja kombiniere ich da einfach
nicht die dritte Sache und letzte Sache
die ich mir rausgesucht habe ist Luca
der Baum kann ich gar nicht das geht
nicht
das wurde mir geschrieben der braucht
Gras auf dem Weg der braucht mehr Licht
der braucht mehr Platz oh nein
Entschuldigung Mister Baum bauen wir den
Setzling halt ab
damit
[Musik]
verarschen
kann ich
also ich habe nichts gesagt ich bau das
hier vorne ab wenn auch das Thema ganz
kurz ein bisschen schöner machen und das
hier werde ich jetzt auch mal abbauen
ich hoffe der fällt jetzt nicht runter
zack den haben wir auch und dann können
wir auch das hier ganz kurzen dicken
schöner machen denn ich habe mir
vorgenommen
[Musik]
soll ich mich verarschen ich habe noch
der letzte Folge noch gesagt da hinten
ist irgendwo was der plötzlich da ich
habe ein Update gemacht mit meinen
Grafikkartentreibern guck mal wie weit
wir jetzt plötzlich sehen können wir
sehen hier von den ganzen Blöcke oder
auf einmal sehen wir das
meine Nvidia RTX 30 90 auch nicht tot
5000 ultra Version kann plötzlich und
das dahin oder was hier äh Silvester
Ostern und Geburtstag an einem Tag also
dahinten werden wir auf jeden Fall
demnächst auch noch mal hinlaufen wir
müssen generell jetzt mal langsam
mitkommen und die nächsten Folgen hier
immer alles so ein bisschen Abarbeiten
von den anderen Inseln vielleicht
entdecken wir dann noch mehr Inseln noch
weiter weg sind keine Ahnung was
allerdings euch jetzt mal ganz kurze
Zeit denn wir benötigen Steine
[Musik]
so Spitzhacke mal wieder kaputt gegangen
dementsprechend machen wir uns mal eben
fix eine neue ihr seht allerdings schon
unten ich konnte jetzt nicht so viel
abbauen allerdings ist das auch nicht
weiter schlimm denn so viel benötigen
wir auch gar nicht ich packe den Eichen
setzen jetzt mal ganz kurz hier rein
damit der gesichert ist und die beiden
Erdklumpen auch noch dann brauchen wir
jetzt unseren Wassereimer da haben wir
zwar Wasser drin allerdings haben wir
jetzt in unendliche Wasserquelle das
heißt dieses Wasser hier benötigen wir
nicht mehr deswegen baue ich das mal
ganz kurz zu ihr fragt euch
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon hey warum und
die fragt euch wahrscheinlich auch warum
ich jetzt das hier machen werde ich
werde nämlich den Lava einmal nehmen und
den hier reinpacken dann nehmen wir
benötigen wir gerade auch nicht mehr
deswegen können wir das jetzt auch mal
ganz kurz wegpacken und was wir jetzt
machen werden ist das hier einmal ganz
kurz aufmachen und auch hier vorne
aufmachen so dass wir die Mauer ist weg
perfekt so dass wir uns von unten hier
anbauen können um jetzt müssen wir ganz
vorsichtig sein um
wie mache ich das denn jetzt
so so
kann ich nicht stehen müssen wir den
hier auch noch mal ganz kurz abbauen so
zack dann sollte ich
muss ganz vorsichtig hier sein ich habe
keine Ahnung so jetzt kann ich hier ne
kann ich noch nicht stehen ich muss das
hier jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder zu
machen oder kann ich da jetzt so rum
springen nee geht noch nicht kann ich
denn da einsetzen
kann ich auch nicht dass soweit unten ah
ey das ist stressig hier ich will
nämlich und das merkt ihr wahrscheinlich
gerade schon ich will oh ein weiter zack
zack so hier einen draufsetzen und jetzt
hier nochmal zu machen jetzt kann ich
nämlich einen runtergehen ja guck mal
perfekt sag ähm ich will die ganze
Fläche hier unten weil eben mit diesen
Stein hier zu bauen so dass ich die
komplette Erde abbauen kann der ein oder
andere Minecraft Profi wird sich jetzt
gerade schon denken Mensch Luca das Gras
das darf nicht weggehen ja ja das werde
ich gleich machen ich bau mir den
gleichen Weg nach außen hoch allerdings
möchte ich hier alles so ein bisschen
schöner machen und da das jetzt ein
bisschen schwerwiegen wird die Arbeit
blende ich euch auch hier von jetzt mal
ganz kurz noch mal eben eine Timeline
ich habe nämlich eine Idee
nicht dass ihr denkt ich gehe hier
planlos ran los geht's
[Musik]
gerade alles hier drunter abgebaut bis
auf die oberste Fläche also hier oben
befindet sich Gras das heißt das werde
ich jetzt mal einfach hier so
zukleistern und alles hier drunter jetzt
noch mal ganz kurz eben abbauen so dass
wir nur hier drunter nachher eine
Cobblestone Schicht haben
[Musik]
die Nacht des angebrochen meine Damen
und Herren ihr seht schon ich habe die
Fackel jetzt mal in die andere Hand
genommen und wir sind allerdings jetzt
auch jeden Moment fertig ich baue noch
diese paar Steinblöcke bzw
bruchsteinstufen sind ja hier noch mal
eben kurz ab dann diesen Block und jetzt
hier einmal kurz schräg hochspringen und
diesen Block und jetzt haben wir
tatsächlich da unten auch noch perfekt
runter
zack wieder auch zack so wir haben
tatsächlich hier alles mögliche abgebaut
alles hier drunter wenn ich jetzt mal
hier ein grasblock abbauen werde seht
ihr schon ist unterhöht von
bruchsteinstufen egal wo ich ein Abbau
auch hier vorne habe ich alles unterhöht
so dass wenn wir uns hier irgendwie mal
verbuddeln sollten oder so nicht direkt
runterfallen und ihr seht auch schon
wenn ich nach hier vorne laufe und mich
umdrehe es sieht deutlich kleiner aus
und ihr seht schon ich habe 57 Erde in
meinem Inventar
normalerweise würde ich jetzt am
liebsten gerne sagen ich gehe jetzt
schlafen und wir sehen uns wieder bei
einem schönen wunderschönen Morgen hier
aber ich kann nicht schlafen von daher
geht es produktiv weiter meine Damen und
Herren ich sicher erstmal die Erde und
alles weitere was ich das sind alles nur
steinsachen die ich hier gerade habe von
daher muss ich jetzt erstmal nicht
sichern ähm wir haben für heute als Plan
eigentlich ja die Monsterfarm gehabt
guck mal jetzt sehe ich das dahin wieder
nicht mehr doch sehe ich
ey ich habe so Bock das alles zu
entdecken ne
auch hier die anderen Inseln ich weiß
nicht ob irgendwo noch Kisten sind mit
Aufgaben oder was weiß ich
aber ich habe so Bock auf dieses Projekt
Digger eigentlich wollte ich heute ja
die Monsterfarm bauen die wach ist
allerdings dass ihr mir dann eine Menge
Kommentare geschrieben habt und prima
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
bring mich um bring mich um bring mich
um mir gar nicht anfangen
[Musik]
ich brauche kein Dach ich weiß nicht ob
diese Phantome jetzt weg sind weil sie
mich ja getötet haben ich glaube ja
[Musik]
ist aber liege ich richtig in die
wirklich jetzt weg
schreib mir das mal gerne unten in die
Kommentare aber es kann ja wirklich nah
liegen also es kann ja wirklich sein von
wegen die kommen töten mich einmal
zeigen mir ey schlaf mal mehr ähm im
echten Leben kriegt man dann eher
Herzrasen wenn man wenig schläft hier
wird man direkt getötet aber gut ähm
aber die sind glaube ich jetzt weg oder
von daher kann ich mir mal meine
Buchstaben nehmen und euch sagen was ich
hier noch machen möchte und zwar möchte
ich hier vorne erstmal das alles so ein
bisschen erweitern mit Erde deswegen
gehen wir auch hier wieder weiter mit
den bruchsteinstufen machen das
natürlich hier ganz entspannt zack zack
zack ich werde auch bevor ich hier
runterfallen ich habe da echt keinen
Vertrauen und nicht die Erde mal ganz
kurz sichern wenn ich jetzt runterfallen
habe ich halt nur ja Steine verloren
deswegen können wir so auf jeden Fall
eine Nummer sicher gehen ich ähm werde
heute nicht die Monster fahren bauen
denn wir benötigen dafür also zumindest
die die ich mir überlegt habe extrem
also wirklich extrem viele Falltüren ich
werde euch dann alles noch mal genauer
zeigen fragt euch wahrscheinlich dafür
fallen das ist irgendwas mit Wasser und
dann fließt das ohne zusammen und dann
werden die Monster gefangen und die muss
ja E24 Blöcke entfernt sein die
Plattform von daher schaffen wir das
heute glaube ich nicht wir haben
allerdings heute schon genug erlebt wir
haben das da hinten entdeckt
und wir hatten unsere erste also
wirklich erstes Erlebnis mit den Phantom
weil ich denke die werden noch mal
wiederkommen leider allerdings nehmen
wir jetzt unsere Erde und bauen hier
vorne alles mal so ein bisschen damit zu
Kleister hier alles voll mit Erde so
dass wir wirklich in der nächsten Folge
dann hoffentlich ein Baum haben in den
werde ich heute auch noch anpflanzen und
äh einfach auf den Kommentar so ein
bisschen eingehen der mir ja auch
geschrieben wurde von wegen dass das
Jahr hatte ich euch eingeblendet dass
das nicht sein kann dass der Baum hier
vorne wächst jetzt habe ich gar keine
mehr
ich bin immer zu übermütig wir brauchen
doch hier noch welche für die Mauern
[Musik]
ich bin so ein Trottel naja egal okay
wir haben auf jeden Fall noch drei Erde
die packe ich jetzt erstmal hier rein
falls wir die für irgendwas noch
brauchen werden Stufen brauchen wir
jetzt gerade nicht mehr weil es dumm
dass ich die gemacht habe allerdings
brauchen wir den Setzling und eine
Fackel die ich hier vorne hingesetzt
habe oder hatte ich gerade noch eine in
meiner Hand nee ich glaube nicht ne ähm
dann setze ich mal eben kurz hier
einfach ein Baum hin mit einer Fackel
das muss doch jetzt möglich sein oder
der Abstand in jede Richtung und der hat
Licht
ich meine gut er steht jetzt nicht auf
dem grasblock aber die wachsen ja auch
auf Erde
obwohl ich theoretisch auf den einfach
hier vorne hinsetzen könnte dass er die
Erde auch schon ein bisschen weiter
gewachsen und ersetzen wir den Baum
tatsächlich hier hin zack er hat in jede
Richtung Platz
ich sag's euch ich warte hier jetzt noch
so lange bis dieser Baum gewachsen ist
ich habe eh noch was zu essen im Ofen
ich mache jetzt eine Pizza so komm wir
sehen uns gleich wieder ihr wartet ja
wenn von Streit die einfach ganz laut
ich habe mein Handy vergessen
tschüss
[Musik]
ich habe ein Baum Gold hat sich das
Warten ja gelohnt meine lieben Freunde
jetzt müssen wir nur noch Glück haben
guck mal er ist auch genau bisschen
gewachsen ey no joke dieses Projekt lebt
wirklich von euren Kommentaren ich habe
eine Axt auch sogar fällt mir gerade auf
hier vorne immer die steinacks raus zack
euer sind wirklich dieses Projekt lebt
genauso Minecraft Staffel 1 von eurem
Kommentaren also schreibt mir gerne
weiterhin Tipps und in die Kommentare
wir warten jetzt noch mal eben kurz auf
dem Setzling gedroppt wird
[Musik]
ich nicht im Stich
ey das Glück ist zurück ich sag's wie es
ist komme ich daran ja zack junge können
wir direkt hier den nächsten Baum
anpflanzen machen wir mal genau hier
vorne ist ja auch schon mal einer
gewachsen und wenn wir sogar noch ein oh
wir haben noch einen jetzt wieder eins
zwei drei eins zwei drei zack
haben wir ein Problem allerdings haben
wir ja sieben Milliarden
bruchsteinstufen die wir einfach so
schon mal provisorisch dahin bauen
könnten bzw könnten wir die auch
eigentlich da vorne auch noch mal
drunter setzen ne unter die Bruchsteine
wo die Mauern an der Seite drauf sind
weil das alles dann so ein bisschen
gewollt haben wird finde ich also hier
vorne können wir einfach auch noch
welche hinsetzen zack zack setzen wir
hier noch welche hin damit einfach alles
so ein bisschen erhöht ist und ihr wisst
ja nicht unter eben nicht unterhöht ist
und ihr wisst ja wie sehr ich auf sowas
achte und dass mir sowas wirklich
wichtig ist von da gehe ich jetzt mal so
hier muss ich hier ganz genau setzen ne
zack das hier alles schön aussieht euch
eine ganz große timelaps während ich den
Krams eben mache
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren die Stufen
hier vorne sind Gesetz seht ihr auch
schon sieht deutlich schöner aus hier
alles vorne gesichert gehen wir auch
hier noch mal so ein Stückchen weiter so
dass wir wenn wir da vorne da mehr auch
noch Erde oder ist das Erde ja das ist
Erde da hinten haben wir auch noch Erde
ey wir haben echt hinten auch noch da
vorne haben wir vielleicht auch noch
Items drin sind ja auch dann
wahrscheinlich diese blöden Idioten die
uns Boxen wollen da haben wir auch noch
Erde und da ganz hinten ist auch noch
Erde also wir haben eine Menge Erde wir
können ja alles aus Erde machen finde
ich viel schöner wenn das Gras ist als
mit diesem Bruchstein aber vielleicht
müssen wir uns da einfach einen
Kompromiss überlegen ich habe auf jeden
Fall noch zwei weitere Setzlinge
irgendwie im Inventar die sind glaube
ich gedroppt worden auch noch von dem
Baum deswegen müssen wir gucken wo wir
die jetzt hinsetzen ich mache einfach
mal einen hier glaube ich äh wir haben
nicht so wirklich viel Platz nee klar
ich könnte jetzt noch jemand den da
hinten irgendwie weiterhin setzen aber
ich glaube ich teile das so oft er hat
ja auch Platz wenn ich ihn hier
hinsetzen ja hier hinein gehen dort
haben die vier Blöcke dann nehme ich den
hier und setzt ihn glaube ich so ein
bisschen hier mit ich von den beiden
hierhin das sollte schon klappen glaube
ich das hier brauchen wir mal eben kurz
ab haben wir auch noch einen
rausbekommen Glück ne guck mal dann
setze ich jetzt einfach noch mal hier
vorne ein Baum hin dann können wir
gucken ob in der nächsten Folge dann
schon der ein oder andere gespannt ist
dadurch dass wir jetzt eh genug Holz
haben können wir auch theoretisch mal
eben
[Musik]
ich glaube ehrlich gesagt dass diese
Situation mit der Fackel gerade schon
gezeigt hat dass wir die Folge mal
langsam beenden sollten wir sind schon
wieder in der Überlänge meine lieben
Freunde von daher sage ich tschüss es
hat mir unfassbar viel Spaß gemacht
schaut mal wie sich das heute schon
wieder alles verändert hat nicht nur
dass wir das hier hinten entdeckt haben
diese komische Festung dahin
jetzt will die Wunder sondern Update war
ich glaube ich muss das Video einfach
beenden ihr wisst was wir heute
geschafft haben ich bin sehr stolz auf
uns morgen geht es nicht weiter denn
morgen habe ich zu tun aber es geht die
Tage weiter ich kann noch nicht genau
sagen man vielleicht in zwei Tagen
vielleicht doch erst in drei Tagen
allerdings könnt ihr mir gern weiter
weiter Kommentare unten reinschreiben
was ich machen soll was in der nächsten
Folge passieren soll allerdings werde
ich jetzt erstmal kacken gehen denn das
muss ich schon die ganze Zeit ich habe
zwei Pizzen gerade gefressen
[Musik]